[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Chris is
in Augusta hi Chris welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi thank you for having me
on really appreciate it sure how can we
help I am three
years from retirement um my student
loans I make my 120 payments I'm in
education for my Public service loan
forgiveness in April so I'll be done
with that um the only debt we have
outside of that is our house and we know
we're going to probably move in the next
five to seven
years um back to kind of where our
people are at um so should I concentrate
on paying off the house or should I
concentrate on building up my retirement
find what are you investing right now
into
retirement um I've had a 403b in quite a
few different places I just Consolidated
those with a Randy specialist I'm a
fiduciary
um it's right at 40 Grand sorry you
broke up with us right at 40 Grand yeah
yeah right at 40 Grand uh my retirement
from teaching will be right at 60,000 a
year um so are you putting anything into
retirement now at the present moment no
because of the student loans and we do
not have a fully
funded
yet okay then you would not be paying
into retirement or extra on your house
either one you would be did you say you
had four payments left you've been on a
private or are they a public student
loan forgiveness for 10
years um you have to make 120 payments
on the student loan
forgiveness yeah I'll meet I'll meet 120
and April
okay well I pray that you are one of the
few that that works for you are aware
that only 4% of the people that apply
for that are actually getting it I am
yeah I've been meticulously keeping my
paperwork I'm not and that hasn't
mattered because there are a bunch of
freaking Liars up there I mean I'm
serious when the last time I looked it
was
1.16% of them are approved which is 98%
are not and you know and I promise you
they thought they had their paperwork in
order so um the whole thing is a
freaking sham but I sure hope you get it
okay so what's the balance on the
loan uh it's more than doubled since
I've had it it's at 225 right now and
that's because you were holding out for
this public student loan
forgiveness um partially but even when I
was making payments it was one of those
stories where you make your payments and
it still grows and grow minimum doesn't
touch it yeah because of the interest
absolutely which makes me want to burn
Washington to the ground um good people
like you having been misled like this I
sure hope they forgive it I'm I'm not
hopeful though uh from a practical
standpoint okay so let's set that aside
your first thing is build your emergency
fund is that your only debt other than
your house yes sir okay your first debt
between now and April build your
emergency fund as build as as big as you
can build it okay and then let's see if
the Forgiveness goes through if it
doesn't go through you're going to have
to deal with the student loan if it does
go through that'll be gone and then we
will move to putting 15% of your income
into
retirement okay and uh the rest would Co
towards anything else you can find you
go towards paying extra on the house
regardless if you're going to move I
don't care if you're going to move or
not unless you're going to move next
month but uh um because three or four or
five years who who the crap knows when
you're going to do that I mean I don't
know you don't know even just a general
feeling you've got that doesn't change
the idea that you need to get a paid for
house so we need to get a paid for house
and a big old pile of money when we get
to retirement that's the game
plan okay I'm absolutely can do that
yeah today yeah let's start on the
emergency fund right now you see
anything else George no that's it but I
mean if that emergency fund it might be
your Saving Grace to start knocking out
these student loans well if it's a Dash
versus a slash they'll reject it that's
how silly these applications have
been and that's not just a Twitter
saying that's an actual syntax I saw an
actual video of that real sad an actual
deal the guys are looking for any excuse
It's just horrible